making his 19th start of the season he's
won his last three and four of his last
five and has been doing a great job of
becoming more efficient letting the
fastball lead the way then here comes
the slider the curve ball has been a
bigger weapon for him as the season has
moved along out of the line third base
out of the rubber he throws swinging a
mission boy he took a lot off that
breaking ball there he doubled up on it
and down goes mullins to start the day
here's mcclanahan's 3-2 pitch swung on
and missed strength three he's throwing
curveballs more than his slider early on
and he's gotten swings and misses from
now both mullens and mancini on it
there's a check swing ball in the dirt
the appeal and strength three he strikes
out the side of the inning and he gets
all three on curveballs to punch him out
well done for shane mcclanahan end of
half an inning right-hander jorge lopez
looking for a strong finish to what has
been a disappointing 20-21 season first
pitch is lined into right santander's
going to have to go to the corner for it
lyle's on his way to second and just
like that the rays have a scoring
opportunity one pinch into the first
inning
and its base is loaded nobody out for
the raise here in the first and that's
too close
to all four that forces home a run
wow scores bronco to third cruise to
second meadow's 82nd run batted in and
the race take a first inning lead all
right well it's three on none out for
jimen choi always puts together a good
at bat now the pitch swinging a liner
hits the mound goes to short onto the
bag at one throw to first double play
scoring on the play though is franco and
down to third goes cruz the rays lead
two nothing but a double play is exactly
what lopez and the orioles were in need
of 2-2
there's a called strike three how do you
like that and an inning that could have
been much worse for jorge lopez
top of the second shane mcclanahan given
his first lead of the afternoon it'll
face the four five and six hitters
here's mcclanahan pitching swinging a
missy struck him out now that was the
slider
four batters face four strikeouts one
away the 1-1
and the pitch is hit hard to left field
that is a fair ball on the line
and toward the left field corner ground
by meadows off the sidewall is throwing
to second base is not in time sabarino
slides in there with his 11th double of
the season and the orioles first base
runner the left-hander throws got him
swinging on a breaking ball down
and mejia blocks it throws him out to
complete the strikeout and shane
mcclanahan has struck out five of the
first seven batters that he faces so a
two out walk to the nine hitter brett
phillips gets him back to the top of the
order and brandon loud well doubled in
the game's first pitch and he blasts one
my goodness way up into the rings it
misses the rings hence to right field
and right on out of the ballpark a
towering homer for brandon lyle and the
rays have a four nothing lead a dome
scraper for brandon loud number 29
and his hot hitting continues bronco
will be on the move a 3-2
there's a curveball called strike three
at the top of the zone race get two more
in the home run from lao it's
four-nothing tampa bay and now fernando
abad begins what will be a bullpen day
rest of the way for the o's through 31
pitches over two innings on monday and
he's back out to try to soak up a couple
more here
here's a drive in the left field by
rosarito that's going to get down and
hayes will cut it off before it gets to
the wall rosa arena with a wide turn at
first and hayes rifles one back in and
he's going to keep randy to a long
single here's mr wendell and he grounds
it up the middle it's gloved by mateo he
flips to martin on the bag at second so
a nice inning for fernando abbad here's
austin hayes hayes a strikeout victim
his first time
a swing and a miss
breaking ball gets him and they throw
down to first from mejia to joy
completes the put out swinging him as he
struck him out again eight strikeouts
now for shane the oil strain one runner
stay at every bag and now here's austin
meadows trying to pick him up the
three-o pitch taken all the way and it's
low ball four another
bases loaded walk
for austin meadows he knocks in his
second run and the rays now have
a five nothing lead here in the fourth
boy
i know it's easy to say while meadows
just went up there and took four pitches
that was easy but the whole key to
hitting is getting a pitch to hit and if
they don't give you a pitch to hit then
accept the walk there's g-man choi he's
over two in the game today the raised
lead is a handful as the plan gets the
sign and now again the right-hander
ready the runners go in the pitch
swinging the ground ball back up the
middle and that's going to get into
center field for a base hit it'll score
a couple phillips will score here's
franco he will score as well and the
rays lead us now seven to nothing in the
fourth inning the step toward third the
kick and the 2-2 pitch is belted in the
ear deep left field by ureas to the wall
and off the top of the fence
meadows heaves it in towards second and
remote is in there standing
he just missed a home run by a couple of
feet trying to start somewhere richie
martin would look to score urias who was
at third with one out here in the fifth
there's a base hit into right field so
an rbi for richie martin as urea scores
and the orioles on the board
one on one out directly to brett
phillips and center who hunkers down a
little bit makes the catch couple the
first pitch out from mullins and mancini
and mcclanahan is out of it again he's
going to make his tropicana field debut
and the left-hander comes on it's ready
to face the three four and five hitters
for the o's the raise up seven to one
hayes swings and misses and ends gets
them a fastball going down and in and he
has struck out all three times and that
is now nine strikeouts for ray's
pitching
leading at first is mount castle he's
been there the whole inning in the pitch
swinging a mess he finally got him
dietrich went up with a fastball and
strikes out two of the three it's ten
strikeouts in the game for the race and
a new pitcher for the o's it is
right-hander connor wade pitch
swinging a miss
a perfectly placed fastball right on the
outside corner and troy goes down on
strikes the 3-2 swing and a miss
connor wade strikes out randy or
rosarita swinging two up two down to the
bottom of the seventh for wade he
strikes out joy now rosarina the 3-2
grounded to the right side this is fair
mount castle grabs it walks to the bag
any over so one two three inning for
connor wade and we're seven complete at
the truck and apparently on for the
third time he's trying to finish it off
after dietrich ends with three shutout
and he's in relief now the pinch swing
on the missed strike three and the razor
and out of the way he's popping him in
pretty good mid 90s 95 again so two down
for ramona
one two
swing a fly ball well hit deep left
center phillips on the run phillips to
the wall it is gone a home run for ramon
urias blasts off his sixth home run of
the season
and the orioles are within seven to two
and there it is
matteo out on strikes the raids win this
one
it's a 7-2 final
as the rays go out to 75
and 47.
you